one of the features of humanity that is
diagnostic of humanity
meaning it's one of the identifying
features of humanity although it's not
unique to humanity is what we call
eusociality that's EU sociality and EU
means good or true or whatever it means
the most advanced stage of in the
evolution of social behavior and that
advanced stage has and this is account
that I've made back and forth because
it's part of my field
you know I it's part of sociobiology
that I focused on being a student of ant
behavior I have found going through the
record of a fossil animals but primarily
among animal societies that exists today
some 20 species no more of a should say
lines of evolution that led to
eusociality what is your sociality
eusociality is the condition of social
behavior in which groups are organized
into some caste or individuals that are
fully reproductive and others that are
little or very much less reproductive in
the extreme becoming sterile workers
they divide labor these less
reproductive workers to support the
reproductive workers so that you have a
group that is fundamentally organized in
that way with the non reproductive
workers think ants think watch think
termites and think then about humans
that can perform specialized tasks
then the group and then you have the
foundation the platform so to speak
we're building immensely complex society
it's those societies that are extremely
complex and/or other than not human and
yet are not intelligent because they
don't have the size to have a big enough
brain are the ants and that's one line
of the 20 then termites that's the
second line of the 20 and those two
groups alone dominate the insect world
just as humans eusocial alone among all
big animals eusocial to a slight degree
but nevertheless a significant one
dominate a planet and that's really what
the significance of eusociality is and
it's why in an earlier book I used the
title the social conquest of Earth so
the question then circling back to what
is the meaning of humanity is in part
how did and why did we achieve
eusociality alone among the African
primates and alone among all the big
animals we know about and that it was
never achieved so far as we know by any
big animals going all the way back to
the early mammals of the Cenozoic era 65
million years and owned into the age of
dinosaurs there were dinosaurs that ran
around on two legs and had arms and
hands that could manipulate things and
heads that might have expanded with
brain if something had happened to them
that made it higher intelligent
Darwinian success but that never
happened that nothing happened until
about 3 to 2 million years ago finally
an old-world primate line developed the
present human condition and now we come
to the question
why only 20 times that's all I can find
and now that's my specialty you know is
studying social insects and related
creatures that have high levels of
social behavior and why is this and now
I'm going to tell you and this is a very
important part of knowing the meaning of
human existence every one of those lines
20 lines without exception as far as we
can determine went through a stage that
what we call pre adaptation that is they
acquired other traits that were not
really social but set the stage to
become new social and that trait is the
following in large numbers of species of
organisms birds are an example many
kinds of insects a female or a pair a
mated pair build a complicated nest and
one that's valuable because of the
effort and usefulness of it within which
they raise young and in the vast
majority of cases in which they get this
far in evolution they put food you know
in the case of a wasp that stings a big
spider paralyzes it and then drop that
into a nest it's built lays an egg and
then closes it so that the spider
provides the food for the full
development of a new wasp that's very
common in a small percentage of these
cases when you look out over the
millions of species of organism animals
rather very small percentage the female
or the mated pair think wasp primitive
watch think the Washington gift for it
gave rise in the ants think cockroach
like insects that gave rise for the
termites
in a very small number of these
percentage the female automated pair
doesn't leave they begin feeding the the
larvae the immature form until it grows
up and then of this bunch of adults is
that the nest and they just first now
what happens if the Chi doesn't call it
knockout you have a knockout of a gene
that removes the tendency to disperse
now they all stay together mom maybe dad
and the children all adults now
and they have no tendency to disperse
and we know from other evidence they
automatically organize themselves for
reasons I can explain but I'm going to
halt and making trying to explain why
that is an unintended consequence of a
whole new other line of evolution mom
and dad become the dominance primarily
because they are first there and they're
off of the biggest and and the the young
become their young their first brood
becomes the ones that goes out and
forages builds new nest cells and so on
and we have a you social species twenty
times only an evolution among the eight
million species one of them finally
after all those hundreds of millions of
years it happened to be a big primate in
Africa went across the line you know
pre-adapted that way and became your
social
you